how's it going everyone it's Warren and
I've got some awesome news for you today
about the current run time for Avengers
endgame for those of you who are not
aware a few months ago Joe Russo came
out and said right now avengers endgame
is sitting at about three hours long but
the final edits have not been done so
although many of us got really excited
to see a three-hour Avengers movie we
didn't get our hopes up too much because
we know the editing process can take a
lot of time off of a movie infinity war
was sitting at about three hours as well
and we know that they took some time off
of that so although we wanted a three
hour runtime we were still expecting
some time to get cut off however the
Russo brothers have recently come out
and said that the film is still sitting
at three hours long in a recent
interview with Collider here's what Joe
Russo had to say I think the studio is
down with what the best story is right
now we think the movie is playing well
and we've had great responses from our
test audiences and we're feeling very
good about where it is we're still doing
work to it we're not done with it again
this is a culmination film of 22 movies
it's a lot of storytelling to work into
it
emotion is an intrinsic part of that to
us when you have to tell a really
complicated story and you want strong
emotional moments with the characters it
just requires a certain amount of real
estate this one in particular feels like
three hours worth of real estate so
according to director Joe Russo the
movie is still sitting at three hours
long and he thinks that it should stay
at three hours long because it's worth
it and if you think about it this movie
is wrapping up the first 10 years of the
MCU and we may be saying goodbye to some
characters that we've come to really
love over time and it sounds like the
Russo brothers just want to give some of
these characters the time and the
moments that they deserve in this film
which is great I think it's something
that we all want now there is a rumor
going around and I just want to
reiterate this is a rumor going around
that there could be an intermission for
the movie for those of you who are not
aware of what an intermission is it's
basically a five to ten-minute break
about halfway in the movie this allows
people to get up and go use the restroom
go get some more snacks without having
to miss any parts of the movie this is
very common for plays but it hasn't been
done for a
in a very long time however with a three
hour runtime I'm sure some people would
appreciate it but again like I said the
intermission is just a rumor for now
we'll have to wait and see how that
plays out so that's it for the runtime
update by director Joe Russo himself the
movie is currently still sitting out
three hours long and it looks like it's
gonna stay there so let me know what you
think about the runtime and let me know
if you would like an intermission in the
movie let me know in the comments down
below and don't forget I started a new
giveaway giving away five imax tickets
so you and some friends can go see
Avengers in-game in IMAX to enter the
giveaway all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel like the video and comment
down below with your thoughts on the
video and your favorite character that
can be a superhero or a villain and if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
can stay up to date on everything Marvel
and Avengers endgame as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof
[Music]
[Music]
you